most people say they don't believe in  love at first sight but I do  unfortunately for me she had no idea  existed I needed to get her attention in  a really big way I have an investment  opportunity you want me to help get you  laid no but not exactly you have to  create the opportunity in your case  we're gonna need something a little bit  more grand what are you getting at who  are you people  certain more auction  you're going to sweep her off her feet  you get to be the hero Oh lonely times  on I'll be in control the whole time  it's perfect  this is part of the deal how was I  supposed to know this was gonna happen  don't poke him what he's dead you want  this to feel real for her or not I  remember you saying that no one would  get hurt you want to tell me what it is  you're all doing out here at this time a  night oh the game has changed a little  bit say you're not just some rich kid  with a crush are ya  my racing  that was awesome  [Music]  go  you  you